This realization about
the Vandermonde matrix
leads us to the inverse
fast Fourier transform.
We're given the values of a polynomial
at the roots of unity, and
we want to recover the coefficients
of that polynomial.
The algorithm is fantastically simple,
given what we've established so far.
Just run the regular fast Fourier
transform only passing in the values,
and the inverse of the root of
unity that we used the first time.
Then divide the result by N.
Recall that the values that
we receive as input here
were equal to the Vandermonde
matrix times the coefficient.
By multiplying the vectors
of these values
by the Vandermonde matrix parameterized
by omega inverse, we end up with
n times the identity matrix times those
coefficients, and so we just need to
divide this result by N in order to get
back the original coefficients exactly.